LOESCH.
THEY ARE ALL AHEAD.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
I AM MOVING ON FROM FAKE NEWS.
THERE IS A NEW PHRASE IN TOWN, A
NEW LINGO.
FAKE LAW.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
FAKE LAWS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT TAKING SIDES
WHETHER YOU ARE LEFT, RIGHT,
INDEPENDENT OR AGNOSTIC, RESPECT
FOR OUR LAWS IS ESSENTIAL.
THEY ARE NOT FAKE, WE ARE A
NATION OF LAWS.
NOW, SENATORS KAMALA HARRIS,
CORY BOOKER, KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND,
ALL THREE EYEING THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
AND THE LEFT INSISTS I.C.E. BE
ABOLISHED.
THE CALL WAS WRAPPED UP THIS
WEEK WHEN HARRIS' ASSERTED THAT
I.C.E. IS PER SIDE OF AS A MONTH
D IS PERCEIVED AS A MODERN DAY
KLU KLUX KLAN.
TAKE A LOOK AS SHE GRILLS THE
DIRECTOR OF I.C.E.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF THE
PERCEPTION THAT I.C.E. TO
ENFORCE THE LAW,.
>> I DON'T SEE ANY PARALLEL.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT PERCEPTION.
>> I DON'T SEE A PARALLEL AS TO
WHAT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY MAN
DATED.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THERE IS A
PERCEPTION.
>> TO PUT I.C.E. IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE KKK.
JUDGE JEANINE: SINCE WHEN ARE
CARRYING OUT THE DUTIES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AKIN TO ACTING LIKE
A KLANSMAN.
SINCE WHEN ARE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
CONSIDERED DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
SINCE WHEN DO WE PERSECUTE MEN
AND WOMEN FOR DOING THE JOB THE
LAW ASKS THEM TO DO.
IRRESPECTIVE OUR LIKE OR DISLIKE
OF A LAW, NO ONE CAN CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THE LAW.
THE LAW IS MEANT TO BE FOLLOWED
AND ENFORCED.
KAMALA, YOU WERE A PROGRESS
CUTER AND ATTORNEY GENERAL.
YOU ENFORCED THE LAW BY
PROSECUTING THOSE WHO DIDN'T
FOLLOW IT.
I DOUBT YOU ASKED THE ACCUSED
ABOUT THEIR PERCEPTION OF THE
LAW, AND I DOUBT YOU EVEN CARED.
IN FACT, WHEN YOU RAN FOR SENATE
YOU PROMISED TO QUOTE COMBAT
TRANSNATIONAL GANGS, WORKING
WITH MEXICO TO PREVENT THEM FROM
BRINGING GUNS AND DRUGS ACROSS
OUR BORDER.
TO FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
IMPROVE HUMAN SAFETY.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO DO THAT
WITHOUT I.C.E.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO CALL?
GHOST BUSTERS?
AS SOMEONE WHO CLAIMS TO
CHAMPION MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE THE ONES MOST
OF IMPACTED BY DRUG CARTELS AND
GANGS COMING THROUGH OUR POROUS
BORDER.
BETWEEN 2017 AND 2018, I.C.E.
SEIZED.
68,000 POUNDS OF -- 687 POUNDS
OF DRUGS.
MORE THAN 430 CRIMINAL ARRESTS
IN CHILD EXPLOITATION
INVESTIGATION, RESCUING HUNDREDS
OF CHILD VICTIMS.
AND YOU WANT TO OPPOSE I.C.E.?
YOU CALL THEM LIKE KKK?
IF YOU DON'T LIKE A LAW, KAMALA,
THERE IS A PROCESS TO CHANGE IT,
AND HERE IS THE RUB.
YOU CAN CHANGE IT.
AS A UNITED STATES SENATOR WORK
WITH THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
EXALTED POSITION TO WHICH YOU
WERE ELECTED.
SPONSOR A BILL, GET SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND GET IT PASSED.
DON'T GIN UP PEOPLE INTO A
FRENZY SUGGESTING I.C.E. IS LIKE
THE KKK WITH IMAGES OF BURNING
CROSSES AND LYNCHINGS OF
INNOCENT AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
LIKENING IT TO INNOCENT MEXICANS
AND CENTRAL AMERICANS.
YOU OF ALL PEOPLE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THE ANGER AND HATE
THAT CONJURES UP.
AS A WOMAN WHO IS HALF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, YOU SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY AND THE
ROLE OF THE KKK PLAYED THROUGH
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
LET ME SEE IF I GET THIS RIGHT.
I.C.E. SHOULD BE ELIMINATED
BECAUSE IT SCARES PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BROKEN OUR LAWS
TO COME HERE.
MANY HAVE ALREADY EXHIBITED
VIOLENCE ALONG THE WAY, IN
TIJUANA AND GUATEMALA.
MOSTLY MEN DEMANDING ENTRANCE AS
IF THEY ARE ENTITLED TO BE HERE.
WHAT YOU ARE DOING IS PLANTING
SEEDS OF FEAR, RESISTANCE AND
RESENTMENT AGAINST I.C.E. AMONG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO RIGHT TO COME
HERE, WHO HAVE ALREADY BROKEN
OUR LAWS TO GET HERE.
AND THEY ARE SCARED?
PEOPLE SHOULD BE AFRAID WHEN
THEY VIOLATE OUR LAWS.
THE PEOPLE THOUGH WHO SHOULD BE
AFRAID ARE INNOCENT AMERICANS AT
RISK IN SANCTUARY CITIES AND
STATES WHERE ILLEGALS WHO ARE
ALSO CRIMINALS ARE GIVEN SAFE
HAVEN.
YOUR CON PUTS THOSE AMERICAN
CITIZENS IN JEOPARDY.
HOW ABOUT HAVING A DOSE OF
REALITY AND NOT YOUR PERCEPTION
NONSENSE.
LOOK AT THESE PICTURES.
KATE STEINLE, AND THE SCORES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS KILLED BY
ILLEGALS.
YOUR PERCEPTION OF I.C.E. AS THE
KKK IS PURE INSANITY.
THIS IS AMERICA.
THE LAW IS THE LAW.
RESPECT IT.
HONOR IT, FEAR IT, FEAR IT.
ANY QUESTIONS?
THAT'S MY OPEN.